plus loin qui continue place aux matchs
des idées confrontation de points de vue
ce soir entre eric heyer et christian de
boissieu
on va revenir sur le coût de ces
nouvelles mesures dans seize
départements bruno le maire les chiffres
à 1,2 milliard d'euros de plus par mois
notre économie peut-elle tenir on va
ouvrir la discussion après les détails
chiffrés et les réactions au sénat c'est
avec l'américaine le nouveau confinement
régionaliser alourdit encore un peu plus
la facture du coc vite pour les finances
publiques car les 16 départements
concernés pèse lourd dans notre économie
à elle seule l'ile-de-france représente
31 % du pib
cent dix mille commerce non essentiels
ils ont baissé le rideau pour un mois
pour les aider le gouvernement poursuit
les ennemis en place depuis le début de
la crise outre la prise en charge du
chômage partiel maintenu jusque fin
avril
l'état continue d' indemniser les
entreprises via le fonds de solidarité
jusqu'à 200 milles euros dans certains
cas des entreprises qui bénéficient
aussi de repères et d'exonérations de
charges voire même d'une prise en charge
de leurs coûts fixes dans certains
secteurs à l'arrêt à partir du 31 mars
l'intégralité des charges fixes vont
être couvertes pour les entreprises de
plus d'un million d'euros des secteurs
du tourisme et de la restauration avec
une indemnisation qui pourra aller
jusqu'à 10 millions d'euros
au total le nouveau confinement coûtera
1,2 milliard d'euros supplémentaires
chaque mois aux finances publiques et 0
2 point de pib selon bercy un chiffrage
jugé optimiste par certains et notamment
le medef mais que défend le sénateur en
marche
xavier iacovelli complètement confiner
les 16 départements on a freiné et donc
il ya quand même de l'activité qui
continuent de s'exercer il ya encore des
commerces qui peuvent ouvrir donc ils
sont ceux qui sont fermés sont encore
aider on maintiendra les aides auprès
des entreprises et auprès des secteurs
les plus touchés
tant que nous ne serons pas sortis de
cette de cette année me maintenir le
quoi qu'il en coûte
en misant sur une reprise forte au
lendemain de la crise sanitaire
c'est la stratégie du gouvernement alors
que bercy table toujours
sur une croissance de 6% d'ici la fin de
l'année avec nous pour le match des
idées ce soir eric heyer bienvenue vous
êtes économiste et directeur du
département analyse et opinion de l'oefe
ceo fille observatoire français des
conjonctures économiques
vous êtes membre du haut conseil des
finances publiques et vous êtes co
auteur de ce livre une autre voie est
possible vers un modèle social écologie
christian de boissieu bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes vice président du
cercle des économistes qui vient de
sortir ce cahier spécial
va-t-on vraiment réindustrialiser la
france et vous êtes professeur émérite
d'économie à l'université paris 1
panthéon sorbonne
eric heyer les chiffres sont assez
astronomiques plus 1,2 milliard d'euros
en plus sur l'ardoisé 0,2 point de pib
on passe à 7,2 milliards par mois
seize départements qui ont un tel impact
s'explique comment parce que l'île de
france c'est le poumon économique du
pays
oui effectivement c'est ce département
mais 41% de l'activité en france
soyez donc effectivement c'est aussi à
peu près 30% d'aider des français donc
effectivement c'est pas n'importe quel
département c'est des départements qui
pèse lourd et d'envoyer ils ont fait une
petite arithmétique qui peut se
comprendre
je pense qu'on peut faire un tout petit
un tout petit rappel en novembre lors du
deuxième confinement donc on tournait
avant à -3 et le gouvernement pensait
que avec le confinement de novembre
qu'on allait descendre à moins 20 et en
fait on est descendu cas -8
donc voyez entre le moins 3 et moins 8
en novembre à enlever que cinq points
d'activités là ils se disent bon on
tient à peu près le même confinement
mais que sur 40 % d'activité donc 40% de
5% mais vous voyez et compte bien vous
êtes quelque chose qui tourne autour de
2 et qu'elle / 12 ben vous arrivez à 0,2
donc oui on peut comprendre c'est qu'ils
ont à l'esprit que globalement le
confinement de qui arrive aujourd'hui
est à peu près de même ampleur mais
uniquement sur 16 départements que celui
du mois de novembre
bon peut-être que ça va être mieux ou
peut-être que ça va être pire pourquoi
ça pourrait être mieux c'est que on
apprend du confinement
c'est à dire que globalement on s'est
bien rendu compte au cours du 2eme
confinement que
par rapport au premier on savait
produire avec le confinement
on savait aussi consommer lorsqu'on
était confiné le click and collect etc
donc c'est pour ça que bercy a été
extrêmement surpris des bons côtés
le fait que ce soit pas très récessif à
au moins 9 ans alors ça peut être pire
pourquoi parce que globalement il ya des
effets qu'on appelle un peu nos
linéaires rien on commence à être
fatigué à la fois moralement et donc du
coup ça pèse sur le moral ça on sait on
pensait que c'était le dernier le second
mais non c'était que le deuxième ce qui
aide à un troisième qui arrivent les
entreprises sont une situation qui se
dégrade au fur et à mesure donc c'est
peut-être la goutte d'eau qui peut faire
un peu déborder le vase donc un peu un
côté négatif potentiellement à côté
positif mais je pense que entre nous
aujourd'hui dire 02 c'est une première
analyse qui on est assez bonne et on
verra ça va jouer quelque part autour de
0,2 il reste sur les 6 % de croissance
l'exécutif il est un petit peu optimiste
où il a raison et côté après le moins et
8,2 pour cent de l'année dernière 2020
après un premier trimestre qui est en
train de se terminer mais qui va
probablement va être négatif en tout cas
zéro ou négatif
c'est assez normal qu'ils aient un
rebond assez fort je pense que les
mesures au fond qui viennent d'être
annoncées rota à mes yeux un peu le
calendrier de la reprise remettent pas
nécessairement en cause l'ampleur de
cette reprise
il décale longtemps et décalé dans le
temps ça veut dire qu'en moyenne sur
l'année
ça peut être un peu plus faible que ce
qui était prévu donc si on fait du entre
5 et 6% borloo je comprends pourquoi le
gouvernement veut s'accrocher 1 6% leur
situation d'incertitude ne faut pas
changer tous les jours la pré viande
passant ce que toutes les semaines ou
tous les mois mais bon il faut mieux
peut-être se tenir assis deux côtés du
gouvernement puis voir venir voir ce qui
ce comment ça se passe dans un contexte
où je reviens sur ce que dit rick il ya
la fois des mesures excessives et des
mesures qui sont moins accessibles
le fait de déplacer le couvre feu de 18
à 19 heures redonne un petit espace de
liberté jaillir qui peut être favorable
sur la consommation dont parlait eric et
c'est donc c'est très compliqué de
modéliser tout ça explose et moi donc
il n'a pas parlé de modélisation il a
parlé de règles de 3com qu'on apprend à
l'école primaire parce que loue
également vient de faire une règle de
trois c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à 0,2
donc je termine en disant que au fond au
delà d'eux est ce qu'on va être entre +
5 et + 6 sur l'année 2021
moi ce qui me paraît important c'est de
dire de toute façon à la fin de cette
année on n'a pas retrouvé le niveau
d'activité d'avant le début de la crise
de 2019 s'est de toute façon négative
voilà donc de toute façon il ya un écart
ce qu'on appelle un output gap année car
de production qui va être à mon avis de
cinq points il faudra probablement
retrouvera ce niveau d'activité si tout
se déroule normalement vers le milieu de
l'année 2022 c'est ça mon avis le bon
critère même sa selle ce qui a été dit à
la fin par christian cet été extrêmement
important c'est à dire que globalement
le plus 6 on peut dire voilà c'est à une
année record mais attention en fin
d'année de 2021 on sera deux à trois
pour cent en dessous du niveau de fin
2010 9 et donc ça veut dire qu'on n'aura
pas à rattraper les niveaux de
production de fin 2019 donc on est en
récession c'est sa définition la
récession ce qu'on vous produisez -
aujourd'hui qui hier est donc si vous
prenez comme point de départ fin 2019
on sera en récession et en plus et même
si on avait retrouvé et un horizon
retrouvé ses niveaux de production ni
voyez memmie 2022 on aura juste
retrouver les niveaux de fin 2019 ça
veut dire qu'on aura perdu à peu près
deux ans et demi de croissance
économique et sans croissant soyez si
vous produisez la même chose en 2022
qu'en 2019 avec un progrès technique qui
continue à alimenter la productivité vos
salariés c'est à dire que vos salariés
sont plus productifs en 2022 qu'en 2019
ça veut dire vous avez besoin de moins
de personnes pour produire la même chose
donc avec une population active qui
augmente le chômage ne peut qu'être là
est présent en 2022 par rapport à 2010
neuf donc ça veut dire augmentation
assez forte du chômage et donc ça veut
dire que la situation ne sera absolument
pas revenue à la normale c'est pour ça
que le la sortie du quoi qu'il en coûte
et va être très longue parce que ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir encore même en
2022 va continuer à aider un certain
nombre d'entreprises et d un certain
nombre de mails
pour justement bas les aider à soi ne
pas fermer boutique soit à continuer à
vivre à se loger et était à manger en
bref j'embraye la tue parce
qu'effectivement dire ça va repartir
vers l'été 2021 c'est compatible à être
le fait de dire que le plus dur était
encore devant nous et le plus dur c'est
le chômage effectif qui progressivement
j'allais dire va remplacer le chômage
partiel
aujourd'hui on a on a maintenu le
chômage et les revenus grâce aux
formules de chômage partiel avec le coup
de quoi qu'il en coûte
et puis les faillites d'entreprises sont
peut-être encore à venir les faillites
de pme parce que vous regardez les
chiffres dernier il ya eu moins de
faillites en 2020 comme 2019 parce qu
ils sont aidés parce qu'elle est vraie
garantie par l'état le fonds de celui
d'arrêter etc
les béquilles et donc le débat pour moi
le débat sans trace et la gestion du
temps c'est à dire que certes je
m'attends à un rebond si tout va bien si
je puis dire vers le milieu de cette
année mais il y aura le chômage est
devant nous le chômage des jeunes
moi c'est la variable qui me préoccupe
le plus je dis ça sans démagogie c'est
parce qu'en tant en tant que prof de fac
peu j'ai en face de moi des étudiants
qui ont des diplômes correct mais quand
pas des boulot correct très bon et donc
il ya cet écart qui va rester là pendant
des années et ça c'est pas uniquement
l'accord 2020 qui a été sacrifié et
c'est dans ce contexte que jeudi dernier
le rapport arthuis a été remis à jean
castex sur la dette qu vidé sur l'avenir
des finances publiques alors ça un petit
peu passée inaperçue et pourtant c'était
très attendu par l'exécutif que dit-il
ce rapport s'endetter n'est plus aussi
dangereux qu'avant grâce à la baisse des
taux d'intérêt sur les marchés
financiers mais attention il faut être
clair sur ce point dit ce rapport il n'y
a pas d'argent
magique et il pointe trois risques une
remontée des taux d'intérêts à court ou
moyen terme vous me direz ce que vous en
pensez
une divergence de la trajectoire de la
dette française avec l'allemagne là
aussi un point intéressant et ne plus
avoir de marge de manoeuvre budgétaires
pour relever les défis de demain comme
par exemple la transition écologique
voilà pour le point de vue des experts
de cette commission présidée par jean
arthuis
un autre point de vue si vous le voulez
bien celui de
économiste olivier blanchard qui était
auditionné au sénat il ya tout juste
quelques jours et côté tant que co
videla il ne faut pas absolument il faut
absolument pas évité à dépenser tout ce
qu'on peut sur ce qui est santé et
protection des chômeurs des gens qui ont
perdu à boulot au moins temporairement
des entreprises qui sont en difficulté à
cause d'une coville on a un espace
fiscal suffisant même si on a une
répétition en 2021 de ce qui s'est passé
en 2001 et même si la pétition en 2022
promettre que dès que la crise que vit
déterminer on va diminuer la dette et l
engagement que je ne ne voudrait pas
prendre j'espère qu'ils ont on pourra le
faire mais ça me paraît dangereux eux
aussi commettre
et là on aborde la question épineuse de
la dette
va-t-elle être réduite ou pas le quoi
qu'il en coûte at il des limites quoi il
faut il faut distinguer le quoi qu'il en
coûte sont les mesures d'urgence est
donc là aujourd'hui temps comme on l'a
dit tant qu' on n'est pas revenu à des
niveaux de production d'avant crise il
faut continuer avec ces mesures
d'urgence un faut rappeler c'est une
crise sanitaire et le gouvernement a
pris des décisions et économique pour
des raisons sanitaires creuse la dette
on est bien d'accord mais bien entendu
puisque globalement bas c'est ce choc
d'activité bas on a on la socialiser
pour les salariés par le chômage partiel
pour les entreprises avec des aides bon
mais ça c'est normal et donc ça fait
augmenter la dette pourquoi la dette sur
pib parce que vous augmentez la dépense
enfin et en plus votre ratio diminue
donc ok donc c'est il est normal que par
le denmat heures diminue donc il est
normal que la dette sur pib augmente
très fortement la question ça c'est
l'urgence
ensuite la question c'est une fois que
la crise était passé
à combien il faut ramener ce ratio de
dette sur pied ça c'est une question qui
est central parce que vous êtes on peut
se dire que la dette n'est pas un
problème en soi et n'est pas un objectif
en soi c'est un instrument
on a utilisé cet instrument pour
permettre d'éviter une crise sanitaire
gigantesque et un nombre de morts
incroyable ok c'était un instrument au
service de cela est-ce que ça a marché
c'est ça qui va faire faire ce bilan c
est ce qu on
bien utilisé cet argent public ensuite
la ce que nous dit olivier blanchard est
très intéressant il ya devant nous un
grand nombre d'enjeux qui soit de
retrouver une souveraineté numérique
clim des débats sur l'environnement des
débats sur les inégalités sur la
souveraineté même économiques et
commerciales industrielles
donc ce sont d'énormes enjeux on peut
potentiellement utiliser cet instrument
de la dette publique pour répondre à ces
enjeux donc est donc dans ces cas là
pourquoi réduire la dette publique donc
en fait la question qui est vraiment
bien posée par une débauche c'est à quoi
sert la dette publique encore une fois
c'est un instrument ce n'est pas un
objectif si on utilise bien mais les
générations futures maine d'angers les
générations futures nous diront merci
d'avoir utilisé si on utilise mal en
revanche bas effectivement les
générations futures vous donnons
seulement vous ne laissez un monde
endettés en plus n'avait pas fait les
réformes qu'il faut mais donc c'est bien
utiliser j'embraye en disant
effectivement le sujet c'est à quoi ça
sert
s'il si les dépenses publiques et la
dette publics servent uniquement
financer des dépenses de fonctionnement
des dépenses courantes on prépare pas
l'avenir si la dette d'aujourd'hui
permet de préparer l'avenir qui
permettra à terme de la rembourser ces
gens à travers le temps c'est autre
chose donc ça c'est le premier roman
vous vous étiez parti de questions sur
les taux d'intérêt et la banque centrale
européenne va maintenir ses taux à zéro
proche de zéro pour certains à 0 10 ans
pour 2021 et probablement encore 2022
la réserve fédérale du côté américain va
faire la même chose le débat c'est sur
les taux longs parce qu'il ya eu depuis
un mois ou deux un peu d'agitation sur
les marchés avant la vie agitation
excessive les marchés surréagissent et
moi en tant qu'économiste j'ai pas envie
de faire comme les marchés j'ai pas
envie de s'y réagir je veux dire depuis
un ou deux mois il ya des débats ce
qu'il ya une relance de l'inflation et
ça fait monter les taux d'intérêt long
terme ou de monter un petit peu bon tout
ça me paraît exagéré c'est vrai qu'il ya
une hausse des prix de l'énergie
il est une hausse des prix des matières
premières mais fondamentalement il n'y a
pas d'inflation salariale avec les taux
de chômage qu'on a dans pas mal de pays
européens et même aux états unis où le
taux de chômage est plus bas y a pas
d'inflation salariale
il n'y a pas d'inflation fondane et le
risque d'un écart de trajectoire de
rapport mais le problème à mon avis
c'est le point de départ il y avait déjà
cet écart on nous sommes rentrés nous en
france dans cette crise qu vide au début
de l'année dernière avec un ratio de
dette publique de qui était presque à
100% du pib l'allemagne étaient 60
l'allemagne a pris 20 points comme nous
simplement ils sont passés 64 à 80 non
la privas blancs dépasser 100 à 120 donc
là nous sommes en train de payer à
travers cette crise le fait que nous
n'arrivons pas à gérer correctement les
finances publiques sur la durée du cycle
économique à travers le temps il soumet
plainte et je termine sur un point qui
me paraît très important dans l'est pour
moi en tout cas dans les débats sur la
dette
je suis presque plus inquiets
aujourd'hui sur les problèmes de
surendettement privé que sur les
problèmes de dette publique
bon il ya beaucoup de dons privés sont
les foyers les deux noms mais surtout
les entreprises en france je pense à
beaucoup de pme ou même pas d'aider plus
que des pme et des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire des grandes piles et iman
profiter des taux d'intérêt proches de
zéro pour recharger pourquoi est elle
plus dangereuse parce que vous avez pas
les mécanismes d'ajustement vous pouvez
voir du côté la dette publique veut dire
on va pas rentrer dans les débats
techniques le fait que la banque
centrale européenne porte une partie
importante de la dette publique
mais même si il y avait un peu de noms
pas je crois pas l'annulation mais un
petit peu de rééchelonnement août
accommodements avec cette partie là de
la dette portée par la bce je vois
aucune raison qui a la même chose du
côté des déprimés alors du côté des
dettes privées ont fait un moratoire sur
les pg e on gagne un peu de temps mais
entreprises et même mêmes ménages et
même
donc il faut raisonner je termine
vraiment ma dernière phrase il faut à
donner sur la dette totale
y a pas que la dette publique dans le
débat il ya aussi la dette privée est un
point de vigilance eric ailleurs oui
mais alors c'est qui a été dit est très
important je suis complètement d'accord
c'est à dire que peut-être que la dette
totale a fortement augmenté mais il faut
avoir la composition de cette dette
totale et ont globalement quand on fait
de l'histoire économique il n'y a pas eu
il n'a jamais eu de grandes crises
économiques à cause de la dette publique
mais dans les pays développés dans les
pays en voie développement quand vous
êtes endettés dans une autre monnaie que
la vôtre ça pose problème mais quand
vous êtes endettés dans votre propre
monnaie il n'y a pas de crise qui est
née d'une trop forte dette
quand il ya vous avez une banque
centrale donc il faut en revanche si vos
acteurs ses citoyens que ce soit des
ménages ou les entreprises sont
fortement endettés
la wii toutes les crises économiques
goyer de la bulle internet à la crise
des subprimes c'était de l'endettement
privé et à un trop fort endettement
privé souvent on va les chercher des
ménages modestes
on va les endettés parce qu'on a un
problème d'inégalité pour qu'ils
continuent à consommer et marc au bout
d'un moment ça explose mais c'est
rarement la dette publique donc je pense
que c'est très important quand même de
regarder la nature de ceux de ce fort
endettement fait que la dette publique
soit très fortement très très fortement
augmenté ces d'un étang en fait ce que
nous disent aujourd'hui des marchés s'il
n'y a pas assez de dette publique
oui c'est quand même les paradoxes et
c'est un paradoxe mais mais pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le seul actif
qui est sans risque dans le monde c'est
de la dette publique et de la dette de
certains états public dont la france est
aujourd'hui ben parce qu'il ya une fuite
vers la qualité
et bien tout le monde veut de la dette
publique un acte est un actif sans
risque donc aujourd'hui enlever cet
actif sans risque mais va plutôt d
organiser des marches alors pour qui ces
nouvelles dépenses publiques pour
qu'elles commerson ses nouvelles
bruno le maire a justement essayer de
limiter la casse en laissant certains
ouvrir d'autres pas je voudrais qu'on
écoute son explication cherche à ouvrir
le plus grand nombre possible de
commerce
malgré tout parce que ça participe aussi
non seulement l'activité économique et
du moral des français mais quand les
fleuristes ou simplement parce que
derrière il ya toute une filière et à
l'horticulture
parce que les fleuristes ventes
quasiment la moitié de leurs stocks au
moment du printemps et donc pour eux ce
serait extraordinairement pénalisant
pourquoi les chocolatiers pas parce que
nous avons pack qui arrivent et qu'ils
font une très grande partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires dans cette période là
donc nous essayons de prendre en compte
la réalité de la situation de chaque
commerçant
voilà bruno le maire qui essaye de
limiter la casse et qui fait du sur
mesure mais cela n'a pas plu à tout le
monde pas à vous en tout cas philippe
marini bonsoir merci d'intervenir en
direct dans ce match des idées vous êtes
ancien sénateur et l'air est maire
actuel de compiègne dans l'oise
vous avez pris un arrêté pour que les
commerces même se dit non essentiels
puisse ouvrir les explications les
justifications de bruno le maire ne vous
allez pas non pas du tout j'ai préféré
le propos de gabriel talent qui avait
dit clairement ce que l'on ne peut pas
faire dedans il faut le faire dehors et
je considère qu'il n'y a aucune espèce
de différence entre un commerçant non
sédentaire qui vend sur un marché et des
produits d'habillement et je relève que
ces commerçants non sédentaires
non-alimentaire ont été autorisés à
reprendre leurs activités depuis la
semaine dernière à la suite je crois
d'une décision de justice et d'autres
bourgs des commerçants sédentaires qui
ont la même activité et que le maire
autorise à vendre non pas dans la
boutique mais sur le trottoir devant le
magasin pour moi cette rupture d'égalité
devant la loi est totalement
inacceptable et condamnable mais ils
sont aidés ces commerçants lier le fonds
de solidarité
gfr je préfère que les gens travaillent
plutôt que de les réduire à la situation
de recevoir des aumônes vous voyez en
tout cas de vivre de transfert d'argent
budgétaire il me semble bien préférable
que des gens qui fondent gérer leurs
ventes dans le respect de la
distanciation et bien ce soit en mesure
d'exercer leur activité et d'obtenir un
revenu un revenu aux nets par cette
activité plutôt que d'être à la charge
de la collectivité publique
donc même le geste de bruno le maire
répété ce matin sur rtl où il nous dit
nous travaillons sur deux options nous
pourrions autorisé la liquidation des
stocks qui normalement n'est possible
qu'en période de soldes et envisager des
compensations financières pour ceux pour
lesquels l'indemnisation du fonds de
solidarité n'est pas suffisante cela ne
va pas non plus les couper tout ce qui
est fait dans le sens de la vie
économique va par définition dans le bon
sens monsieur de la palisse l'aurait dit
mais je vous répète que les oppresseurs
des produits d'activités à des
subventions publiques
surtout quand je bois où nous en sommes
en termes de finances publiques
restez avec nous évidemment et n'hésitez
pas à intervenir si vous le souhaitez
eric heyer
c'est vrai qu'il ya une distinction
alors est ce que c'est une rupture
d'égalité je ne sais pas mais entre
différents commerçants ce que vous avez
trouvé sakho est rond non c'est sans
doute pas cohérent effectivement qu'est
ce qui est essentiel non essentiels
enfin je vous avoue c'est quand même un
débat extrêmement compliqué je n'aurais
pas que la place du gouvernement parce
que ce qui est tout ce qui est ce qui a
été dit par philippe marini et et
entendable est assez légitime
bon par ailleurs il ya quand même une
crise sanitaire par ailleurs et on sait
que c'est par la distanciation social
qu'on va s'en sortir tout de même et
donc comment fait-on on peut pas fermer
les écoles parce que là c'est une
choc énorme en termes d'égalité scolaire
et on peut pas charmer les cantines
parce que c'est ça qui permet d'avoir
aux enfants un repas chaud est assuré
cela donc on ne peut pas toucher aux
écoles ont fait revenir les gens au
travail donc voilà donc il ya un moment
il faut c'est vrai que quelque part
tenter de limiter les déplacements des
personnes faire des choix cornéliens
et donc c'est vrai que c'est essayer jeu
c'est extrêmement compliqué sans doute
et un médecin serait plus à même à
répondre à cette question mais comment
fait-on alors après on voit que le son
expérience moi j'habite en centre-ville
à paris je peux vous dire que le fait
que les commerces ne soient pas ouverts
j'habite vers chapelet il y a plus
personne dans la rue et donc on se dit
ah bah oui ça marche il ya moins de
personnes qui sortent donc si on pense
que c'est tout de même en allant dans
les commerces dans les grands centres
que quelque part le virus circule il va
bien falloir qu'on prenne des décisions
mais encore une fois je tous les
arguments sont légitimes entendable la
distinction non essentiels essentielle
c'est c'est affreux mais quelle mesure
doit-on prendre pour éviter bas qu'il y
ait un engorgement dans l'est dans les
urgences etc
enfin j'avoue que c'est compliqué qui
font du labri moi j'entends et je suis
d'accord avec beaucoup de choses que
philippe marini nous sommes nous étions
étudiants ensemble il ya quelques années
vous l'avez compris c'est quelques
années pour toujours quelques années je
suis ravi que les chocolatiers soient
ouverts à titre personnel donc ça m'a
fait plaisir
je suis désolé que les passings toit
fermé mais tout ça est assez arbitraire
je suis d'accord et ya pas de ça fait un
an qu'on tourne autour de ce sujet et
une cohérence économique ou pas cette
fois pas sûr mais je veux dire par
rapport à ce qu'a dit rick escaliers
philippe ce qu'on dit eric et philippe
le débat à nouveau on est on est de
confronter à l'arbitrage entre le
sanitaire et économique à nous séduire
c'est ça la question qui est posée
alors si la solution philippe et
faudrait peut-être qu'ils qu'ils
précisent s'il estime que tout est
respecté qui a pas de risque et c'est là
où gagnent sur l'économique samper sur
le sanitaire mais mais ça dépend de la
manière dont ça se fasse contre
proposé avec s'extasie donc c'est pas
c'est pas un problème théorique c'est
c'est une expérience dont il faut
évaluer les conséquences avec un peu
quelques jours ou quelques semaines de
recul et moi avec a priori je ne sais
pas aussi que l'arbitrage ici sur cette
question parce que ça amène flamand dans
les rues philippe marini oui si vous le
permettez
l'état nous a parlé longtemps du couple
maires préfets et puis ensuite de la
territorialisation et puis tout d'un
coup c'est le régime tout carcan verront
concertation on apprend de la bouche
inspiré du premier ministre ce que sont
les compromis qui viennent de s'établir
péniblement au sein de l'exécutif
bon moi je considère que sur des sujets
comme l'a dit christian qui sont des
sujets très concrets
on devrait laisser une part au pouvoir
local au pouvoir territorial
la situation n'est pas nécessairement la
même dans une ville et dans une autre
tant en termes de taux d'incidence de la
pandémie et de d'encombrement des
services hospitaliers de la réalisation
que pour ce qui est de l'organisation
des marchés
réponse que l'an dernier à un moment
donné on a été plus empirique un tout
petit peu plus décentralisateur
aujourd'hui donc c'est aussi cela que
traduit ma démarche
on ne peut pas de paris tout tout tout
régenter ce n'est pas n'est pas
raisonnable et puis enfin le vrai sujet
sanitaires pardonnez moi c'est la
vaccination
je veux dire que nous serons dans vingt
stoppa niveau permanent et nous
continuerons à créer des injustices
multiples et d'ailleurs inévitable et là
tant que le taux de vaccination n'aura
pas dépassé je ne sais pas deux tiers 70
% 75 % des françaises et des français
quel que soit leur âge
or il faut bien admettre que nous sommes
très en retard et que l'anticipation
à cet égard a complètement manqué et que
l'une
européenne qui a attaché beaucoup
d'importance à négocier des quantités au
meilleur prix possible n'a pas
nécessairement de par son fonctionnement
aider les gouvernements des différents
états à trouver en temps utile des
situations et répondre aux besoins de
leurs opinions publiques
rapidement je suis d'accord avec bien
sûr on est tous d'accord avec le fait
d'accélérer cette vaccination
la frontière l'endroit on met la
frontière entre l'essentiel des notes
essentielles d'une certaine façon
dépanner été relativement dépendante à
mon avis du riz du rythme de vaccination
sauf à dire si on si on avait atteint
déjà aujourd'hui les nuitées collective
duré plus de problèmes y aurait plus de
problème de la frontière donc c'est sous
cet angle là qu'il ya un lien entre les
deux questions est deuxième et dernière
remarque quand j'entends monsieur le
maire quand j'entends ce que ce que dit
bercy
j'ai le sentiment que le le côté fluctue
remet de cette frontière était loin
d'être terminée je pense ça va continuer
dans les jours qui viennent et en
quelques secondes eric heyer
philippe marini parlé de décisions
prises depuis paris j'ai envie de dire
même prise depuis bercy
plus précisément on voit que bercy
décide de tous les arbitrages et y
compris par exemple au détriment de la
culture dont on n'a pas le temps de
parler ce soir mais c'est vrai que c'est
bercy qui décide quoi alors c'est bercy
qui décide mais on a bien vu tout de
même que là ce confinement était
régionale enfin et c'était d'aider
réellement donc il y avait gamme des
départements qui étaient soumis à un
confinement un peu plus strict que
d'autres y avait bien du coup une
décision quand même qu'ils n'étaient pas
homogènes ce n'était pas la même
décision dans tous les départements donc
on va petit à petit mais oui
effectivement c'est des décisions qui
partent duo avec signe alors un petit
mot calmes sur l'européen c'est à dire
que je suis d'accord que si d'un point
de vue sanitaire l'europe est une
catastrophe mais si on fait tout de même
un petit parlé avec le premier sujet
dans lequel on a évoqué il ya eu des
grosses percée par contre reading rose
la grosse avancée d'un point de vue
économique et la dette publique s'est
elle est soutenable c'est en grande
partie parce que la banque centrale
européenne a fait son travail par
rapport à la crise de 2008 sur l'europe
aujourd'hui
en dette au niveau européen on s'endette
on ne repère pas compétent du mode
manuel et enfin d'un point de vue
sanitaire ça c'est vrai on s'arrêtera
sur ces mots très positif sur l'europe
merci à tous les trois merci philippe
marini d'être intervenu dans ce match et
merci à tous les deux dit avoir
participé fin de cette émission
dans un instant auditions publiques
l'invité ce soir patrick mignola
président du groupe modem à l'assemblée
nationale demain bonjour chez vous dès
7h30 oriane mancini recevra notamment
olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]